hello there and welcome once again to
Android design in action I'm Roman Nurik
hey guys my name is Adam Kosh and hi I'm
Nick butcher and today's episode is all
about common UX issues or anti patterns
anti patterns as we'll call them so
let's just jump into the slides here
since we have a lot to cover just a bit
of background our team the developer
relations team for Android we do lots
and lots of different reviews for apps
we will look at apps into both a formal
and informal setting formally you know
internally we have a review process that
we look at apps where this is completely
separate from you know editorial you
know featuring anything that we just
look at apps and we provide feedback to
you know some of our app developers that
we work with and then in an informal
setting obviously we're always you know
looking at apps getting you know apk
links sent over to us on Google+ and
we're you know looking at them and in
providing our feedback and so you know
over the past you know a few years of
doing this I guess we've noticed a
couple of trends a couple of recurring
issues that seem to affect a lot of apps
not every app for certain but lots of
apps and so we wanted to put together an
episode of Android design in action
where we we highlight the you know top
10 items that we keep seeing over and
over again so Before we jump in anything
else you guys want to say about about
our review that's what you meant by
phone one an informal setting up what
you meant like sometimes we review apps
in the bar sometimes we should not you
have nobody good ideas at a gala maybe
okay all right so let's jump in so these
are our top 10 Android UX anti-patterns
Before we jump in a lot of a lot of this
stuff is not necessarily negative it's
really constructive criticism the the
idea is that you guys kind of take some
of this some of this feedback and see
how you can improve your apps and so you
know with much love these are our top
ten anti patterns that we've
so let's jump in the first is and we
have funny little titles at the top so
yeah enjoy the first is thou must load
this or else basically modal loading
dialogues and these are basically any
it's pretty obvious right it's it's
dialogues that appear that say loading
or or saving or sending or or whatever
and you can't sometimes you can't even
press back to cancel if you have poor
network connectivity there's just no way
out except for pressing home and it's
one of the easiest ways to kind of tick
off your users especially those that you
know like I said aren't in a good
connectivity setting or those that you
know simply are very quick you know
they're trying to do a bunch of things
at once the other thing I'll quickly
point out is one of my pet peeves is
when you throw up a loading dialogue
when switching tabs because basically
you switch to a tab maybe you
accidentally chose that tab and now you
have to wait for that tab to load to
switch to something else so the solution
to this is really to try to use inline
loading spinners instead like in this in
this little graphic here or you know
better yet I just try to load data in
the background where possible so that
you can generally just avoid shouting
loading spinners so that's that's kind
of my my I guess the number ten in the
list anything else before we move on
guys one thing that just really annoys
me though is when I touch on a list of
items and I go to the details and then
it throws up that loading spinner then I
hit back and I kind of go back to the
list items again it's just so
frustrating so yeah I think Emily's
diagnosed like a back button a fairly
poor UX like generally anything that
that's blocking and I think that says
you have to deal with this first and
this is completely avoidable like
unavoidable then try and avoid dialogs
but especially learning dialogs get my
act
absolutely okay all right on let's go to
number nine in the the wise words of MC
Hammer cast and then all right that's
our choice so you know we've brought
this up many times in a dia and this is
definitely a recurring theme we see when
we're looking at apps so the first one
is small touch targets so really all
touch targets should be four
dibbs we did right here that could go
down to 30 dips if you absolutely need
to but really 48 dips is what you should
be aiming for why because that sort of
maps to roughly 9 millimeters or I think
somewhere between 7 & 9 with a little
bit of variability which which really
you know ends up being the perfect touch
size for a perp for the average person's
fingers so unless I guess you're
targeting a particular user group with
extremely small hands maybe babies
should really be shooting for 48 dips
here and then the second one and this is
something we see frequently all the time
is no touch feedback and if you put an
app in front of any of us you'll
probably see one of the first things we
do is we actually go and touch something
and then we slide our finger off a
little bit just to see if there's any
touch feedback there so it's it's a
pretty common mistake to make especially
when you're not using the standard
button components because you may have
to do a little bit of extra work to sort
of add that touch feedback but it really
means that your app feels much more
responsive and it's I think it's also
the no touch feedback as well as the
previous anti-pattern it it really
changes the your apps feeling of
perceived latency when things don't
respond or you can't do certain things
there's an increased sense of perceived
latency or where users perceive that
your app is slower than it actually is
so it's one of the fastest you know
people talk about speed all the time
let's make her out faster faster faster
it's not just about raw speed it's
really about perceived speed yeah the
funny thing I think oh go ahead big
sorry I was going to say I think it's a
really important win so we move towards
like digital interfaces where we you
know the holo style is all about
whitespace and typography and so on and
it's really important to communicate
what is capable you know what is you
know you can interact with and I think
touch feedbacks going to instantly react
Steve and lights up the entire area
which you can interact with will kind of
communicate back to you and so you'll
know next time I this is you know the
area have to play with it's really
important exactly cool all right so we
move on yeah so number eight visual
design I think this was I think this is
a the one I'll talk about so in general
design does not mean playing with
Photoshop until
you know you use all of the effects like
until you you know use all the the layer
effects like here on the left of the
drop shadows and all that there are a
couple of concepts here going on
basically you know when thinking about
visual design for your app focus really
on content rather than chrome so you
know users really aren't installing your
app just to see the pretty you know
buttons and the pretty you know top bars
and and all these you know fancy things
they're really installing your app
probably because they care about the
content or the functionality that you
offer so really make that shine you know
if you're going to dedicate any sort of
visual attention or visual resources to
anything it should really be the content
additionally you know a couple of other
things in the realm of visual styling
for your app try to be consistent all
too often we see apps that you know have
three or four different you know button
styles or checkbox styles or something
and they're kind of mixing and matching
and and generally that's that's a there
can be a result of too many people too
many cooks in the kitchen too many
people working on the same app so where
possible try to introduce consistency
using things like androids
styles and themes framework to basically
make it really simple to have consistent
styling across your app and the last
thing in the realm of visual design is
is poor attention to detail so it's not
only about you know getting the high
level things right like getting the
right color and getting the right you
know I guess basic theme down it's
really about attention to details of
respect to typography making sure you're
using the right type of graphic palette
also with respect to metrics that's one
of the biggest things that people do
wrong that we see is people don't use or
developers don't use the right spacing
so you know there's too little space or
there's too much space you know around
an element or two small margins around
the sides and things like that you know
can really break the concept of
alignment and visual balance within your
app so definitely you know focus on
these things and I think certainly we've
covered most of these in Android design
in action in episodes past but
definitely this is this is one of the
things you should focus on
anything else before I move on okay
let's do it
so in at number seven we've got living
in the past or as we said if your app is
living in 2009 your users are going to
have a bad time it rhymes
yeah I'm just visiting Leena the South
Park ski instructor there sorry right so
the first point when I make about this
is you know the menu button of shame or
the legacy menu button is kind of very
little excuse like all of these points
we've got on on the slide right here
generally point towards the fact that
you're not kind of updating your
application to move with the latest I
mean it's one thing to look at the
platform from distribution stats and say
hey this you know some my users are on
all the devices but that's kind of not
really being fair to the users who are
on newer devices or have these kind of
shiny new devices probably people who
are downloading installed on your
application more often so we really
think you need to be kind of looking at
you know maybe not the blazing latest
release but here we said you should be
targeting at least API 16 which is and
the first jelly bean release which came
out at what Google i/o last year to over
a year old if you're not kind of
targeting that newer version you're
probably like missing out some new
functionality as well as probably
degrading some of the functionality
because some of the shims that this
system has to put in place like the
compatibility mmm so if you're below 14
I think you've got a real big problem
because you're going to get this legacy
menu emulated button button of shame can
look terrible especially on devices like
the HTC One where it puts up this big
bar across the bottom of your
application and really ruins it all
they've have time and attention I hope
you spent on the rest of your design so
really think about that and and the
other thing is not kind of picking up on
the modern look and feel like say for
example if I'm using an application and
it has some kind of gingerbread area
error and styling for example it might
look kind of hollow but then you touch
something and you get that kind of
orange highlight or you scroll you get
that legacy kind of rounded scroll bar
maybe you're familiar of that that kind
of really just breaks the experience of
instantly it's just like well that
unexpected what's going on there so
wherever possible you want to be using
the latest and greatest styles and
building on top of them using them as
your foundation so doing thing I think
what I often see this is where spinners
as well so you'll be using an
application and they've set a style on
the on a progress but an indeterminate
progress spinner often set the style to
indeterminate and they haven't used the
appropriate kind of theme default syntax
for it so you get kind of a gingerbread
style spinner it just looks completely
gross and out of place right the others
it the problem with the loading spinner
is that the gingerbread arrow unused
frame animation so there are basically
eight frames ecliptic and so on and the
hollow spinner is actually using a tween
animation so it's a much smoother
rotation you actually see each
individual frame as it gets rendered or
not each individual frame but each point
in around the circle so it's much much
better to use the holo style
indeterminate loading spinners yeah so I
think I guess the takeaway from from
this what we're trying to say here is
use the latest and greatest and kind of
like builds on top of it x1 moving on
okay poodle Android who's implanting
this is me again so there's a page on
the design guy called pure Android and
it is what it sounds like it's talking
about don't borrow metaphors from other
platforms
don't use kind of iconography or other
such from other platforms if you're if
you're building an Android experience
for your Android users then build an
Android experience I think we did a
whole show about branding and
consistency whether you should be
consistent with you know what that means
what you should be consistent with if
you want other platforms for example so
I'll refer you back to that for the kind
of deep deep dive on this topic but
essentially if your app doesn't like
conform to the Android platform you're
the one who's going to look out of place
you know if I'm using 50 60 70 apps on
my my Android phone and I switched you
up and your app doesn't look and feel
how an Android app should look and feel
then you're the one who's going to stand
out so some very very common things you
might see might be for example using
right pointing carrots to indicate that
this you know
level below of information that just
doesn't make sense on Android you mean
we have a very different kind of default
load transition animation so you know
pointing right and then something
expanding and kind of fading you know
just doesn't line up as well as going
back it doesn't slide back their way so
I guess this is no spatial metaphor
there especially with androids use of
the horizontal metaphor for moving
between content so like tabs for example
you might page between them like this
but then you know if there's a why arrow
does that mean I'm going down or I'm
going side to the other tab it just
doesn't work so respect that tabs
you know there's android on android tabs
go at the top so if you're doing tabs at
the bottom basically you're going to
look out of place and it's going to be
what why is this app doing this
differently and the last one we pulled
out is just like wholesale borrowing
from other platforms this is if you see
say iconography from another platform or
you know a picker from another platform
which just looks completely out of place
just don't do it just use the defaults
it's what your users expect and doing
otherwise is being kind of quite a
Paragon and aggressive towards them so
stick with what the platform gives you
yeah can that covers it well yeah let's
move on all right I think was this me
this made me think this was me so uh
another and actually this is this plays
into what Nick was mentioning about you
know branding where do you kind of which
metaphors do you use which UI patterns
do you use this is the antipattern of
the navigation is my brand or you know
everything the entire app should be mine
right I should control everything and
generally that's the case you know you
should control you know visual styling
you should control you know the
information architecture and we did a
whole you know segment on this but there
are a few things that you should really
try to to use from the Android design
guidelines obviously I mean pure Android
that's very important but also anything
related to core app navigation so things
like the action bar things like tabs and
also things like the navigation drawer
so this anti-pattern is it's basically
like you know apps that reinvent the
wheel by creating a custom top bar with
like a centered title and then like two
actions one on the left one on the right
or maybe kind of a very different
looking navigation drawer indicator this
this basically isn't an
I mean Android users expect an action
bar at the top the the title should be
left aligned there are certain things
that should should exist in the action
bar navigation in the top left actions
in the top right or very poorly
implemented action bars and generally
this is because of the lack of I guess
the lack of a toolkit that allows you to
bring the action bar earlier versions of
the platform but you know
actionbarsherlock has existed for quite
a while and that's the great great
choice but also actionbarcompat was
recently released so for designers and
developers well for developers
especially if you're if you're rolling
your own action bar just stop stop doing
it and just use actionbarcompat but also
navigation jars I'm not going to go
through all the details here but there
are a lot of specifics and what should
what should and what shouldn't go into
navigation drawer it generally anything
that's not really core app navigation
something that the user is going to be
switching between somewhat often that
probably shouldn't go into navigation
drawer and we did it another you know
full episode on this I won't go into the
details but if you're a developer you
should definitely be using drawer layout
an action bar drawer toggle try to avoid
using any of the other libraries out
there that don't implement this this way
because you're not going to get the same
interactions that the platform provides
and in this van I just want to quickly
point out some things that shouldn't go
in the navigation drawer so home
Explorer shop now my profile that's fine
and that's it's kind of core top-level
navigation things like search its
navigational but by platform convention
should really go into the action bar so
it does not belong here
settings also in the action overflow
help about send feedback that should all
go into the action overflow anything
linking to other apps that your brand
offers that should probably not go here
because chances are folks don't care
about every app in your portfolio so
generally you want to put that if you do
want to place it in your app put that
somewhere you know deeper in the app
maybe about you know about you know your
brand and in their list the other things
and then obviously the random things
that people will never click like my
sister's friends website that a promise
is really awesome please check it out
that
does not belong in the navigation jar so
try to keep it simple try to keep it to
what's in the guidelines let's move on
alright so number four is a custom
non-android sharing now I will note here
that the screenshots in this in this
slide are actually the the positive or
the good sharing mechanisms not the
examples of bad or not Android sharing I
was looking for good examples of that
but there's a lot of them and we see it
a lot but I didn't want to sort of doing
any particular app out there so putting
some positive examples positive
reinforcement is named again so you know
Android has a great ability to share or
use this action send intent between
applications so you should always use it
always make it available to your users
again along the same same things that
we're talking about before it's just a
frustrating experience when the user
goes to try and share something and
they're stuck with one or two static
options as you can see here on my phone
I have tons of different apps installed
I shared the different apps all the time
and so not having the ability to choose
the one that you want to share to is
just a really frustrating user
experience just to quickly go over the
sort of examples here on the left you've
got the share action provider and so
that's that's something that goes
directly in the action bar and actually
has a pop-up menu that brought drops
down there and you can choose from your
most recently or most frequently shared
applications and then the second one is
the standard system share dialog that
you can trigger using that action send
intent and then on the right this is a
custom example actually from the timely
app which I really like so in this case
they actually have kind of listed just a
few to start with you can see that they
have this little drop-down at the bottom
saying more which actually goes and
programmatically fetches the rest of the
sharing options available so I guess the
moral of the story is try and always use
the system share intents if you really
must for some reason you know have a
list of specific networks maybe it's
part of your business goals or something
else you should still complement it with
the standard action send by sharing
alongside
yeah okay move actually one more thing
this actually is in the pure Android
guidelines right so again kind of don't
don't try to violate any of the pure
Android guidelines try to adhere to
those as best as possible and this is I
think it's called don't hard-code links
to apps in your app yeah and actually
I'm sorry one last thing I'm from a
development standpoint it's actually
much easier to use the system show
intense then go and often and do it all
yourself so I mean from a development
standpoint it's also a positive thing
absolutely
all right moving on mimicking your
native with webview I think this is this
is me again so you can see here some
quick examples and left we've got the
ADI a YouTube playlist loading in a
webview it's a great experience there to
browse the ABI videos this is this is
really just a bit of fun because
actually if you load the YouTube website
it looks fairly decent because it's just
the mobile version on the right there
you can see the great example of the ad
or the Android design in action or Adi
application that's in the Google Play
Store which looks fantastic it's very
very responsive works on all different
screen sizes
it really works great so let's move to
some of the talking points so first
point it's not genuine it's kind of like
lying to your users so it is a it's not
really the the most positive experience
especially if you're sort of taking up a
lot of the core UI with a webview and
falling from that you know the
performance is generally going to be
degraded you know if you have a drawer
that's built using a webview you're
going to notice that it's not as smooth
it's not as responsive it just doesn't
behave like the user would expect and
then from the example on the previous
page you know don't package up a web app
in an apk just to be on Android just for
the sake of being in the Google Play
Store to be on Android you know we love
web apps web apps work great on Android
but whether user expects them is in the
browser in the Chrome browser or the
system browser where they sort of
understand that the UI conventions and
they're viewing a web page I mean also
use web views at all right I mean a
certain component where it makes sense
like Gmail for example renders HTML
correct
you know email it makes perfect sense to
use a web view control there or if
you're rendering some like news content
and perhaps that make sense the other
thing don't build your whole application
of this exactly yeah so another good
example is pocket which uses a webview
or HTML to render the article views and
it actually works really well in those
particular cases we're really saying
don't just like throw a webview into the
entire application and make it take over
the sort of standard core UI elements
yeah one last point I wanted to make
about you know web apps and versus
native apps is you know there's a
tendency for brands to be like oh we
need to be on Android right and you
mentioned this right but we need to be
on Android so we need to make a native
app but you know a ton of Android usage
that's regular users most of them use
the browser quite a bit so that you're
not losing those users you're just gonna
they're going to you know access your
experience through a different mechanism
and if you're if you think that you know
a web-based solution is the best option
then that's going to work for a lot of
users so don't don't immediately jump
into oh we to just you know have this
kind of hybrid thing where we just throw
our entire web app into into a native
apk so that just doesn't work yeah and I
think you'll find if you if you do go in
through a webview and make it take over
the entire application you're going to
sort of violate a lot of these other
things we've talked about today like the
touch feedback the touch size the the UI
elements living in the past all these
things very hard to do if you're going
to use a webview to take over your
entire application move on yeah moving
on
nikka so do we have poor onboarding and
UX so this is one of my personal
bugbears like when you fire up an
application and like 101 different
things are competing for your attention
at the same time and none of them what I
look at your app for which is probably
to see the content it's a personal you
know frustration of mine so there's many
things that people tend to throw in at
the first run so things like requiring
registrations straightaway a splash
screen and you know putting a popping
popping up their own kind of log and
provider and so on and so forth and all
these things just a road bumps very
speed bumps stopping me from doing what
I launched the app to do which is see
some content so I would much rather
see an application it gets me to content
as quickly as it can and then delays any
necessary kind of steps until they are
you know truly like the last minute so
logon for example let me you know see
some content and try and interact with
it and if I try to do an interaction
which requires log on that then prompt
for it because at that point I can
understand exactly why you're asking for
this thing and so on and splashlings are
never personal bugbear it's in our
design guidelines forever that you
shouldn't really use flash means they
that they don't really serve much
purpose other than delaying you from
getting to content you want to see so if
you think that it's the only way to
embed branding into your application
then I think you have bigger problems
there really are much better ways to
kind of provide branding to your
application like using the action bar
and your palate and so forth so I don't
accept that as an argument at all and
then conversely there's lots of things
you can use to actually ease the
onboarding process so for example and
integrating with popular popular logon
providers so things like Facebook
Twitter Google+ have excellent kind of
single click and sign-on providers and
you can even do you know intelligent
things like use the package manager like
a system component on Android to detect
if the user has like one of these native
applications installed which is you know
a pretty strong indicator that they you
know a user of one of these logon
providing service to have services and
you know use that to show or hide or
reorder your logon options and they'll
provide a much slicker UX if you really
really must like for someone to log in
with like a username or password for
example then this in clever stuff you
can do like my phone already knows a
bunch of my email addresses or user
names which is saved on the system you
can query for these and use them to
autocomplete or pre-populate fields you
can query a system for the users you
know full name or and telephone number
and so on and so forth so you can you
know pre-fill a bunch of different
addresses and i've even seen some
applications going a step further you
know if you really have to do a sign up
on the phone and do you really want to
have to sit there and kind of like peck
out like a password why not like offer
to auto generate some random string and
let them kind of lay and hit refresh to
to rotate it to say different because
the user can always just reset it later
they have their email address and
they're probably probably not going to
remember their password anyway I mean
it's just like I just had put in some
password and get get past the screen so
exactly so basically do everything you
can to kind of like simplify the first
user experience and get you to content
as soon as possible I think too often
when we're like you know designing
developing apps you've looked at the
application so many times right that you
can speed through that process or you
know you logged in the first time enough
that you can continue to look at the
subsequent screens and you forget about
you know the first impression that
you're making on to users so it's super
important I mean this becomes even more
important if you're lucky enough to
become featured or suchlike or picked up
by a blog or something like that you be
surprised at how many users will install
your application without fully
understanding the value proposition
exactly understanding what it does just
to try it out and if the first thing you
see is a bunch of overlays explaining
how to do stuff and logins and pop-ups
they're forcing you to take more steps
before you get to the actual content to
show them the actual value then you'll
have a huge kind of fall-off on the on
the converse site you know like
completely on the opposite end of the
spectrum if I open up your app and I see
you know an immediate like empty
ListView with nothing there you know
just like a little plus button in the
top right and just look really just an
empty screen that is also a poor
communication of the value proposition
so empty states which we'll talk about
very briefly empty states for for
collections are actually a really
valuable way of communicating that
alright moving on I think we're running
low on time the last one number one
should have done a drum roll but I guess
we did another time Android is not just
phones in portrait what this means is I
mean if you're developing an app and you
know you have a phone UI don't lock it
into portrait make sure that the user
can rotate into landscape quite a few I
think something got chopped off here
there's supposed to be a graphic here
but whatever quite a few users actually
you know use phones in portrait in
landscape rather especially those with
you know maybe car docks or or even
desktop docks so you know for example if
you're a sports app there should be kind
of a landscape dashboard view or
something especially if I'm in a card
and some sort of dock if you're a you
know if you're a another type of app if
you're like a news app or something
consider you know you know think about
how you can kind of rearrange your text
so that it works and potentially even
you know switch around your interactions
may be horizontal goes to vertical swipe
person's like that
not really sure but I mean the point
here is don't force your users to hold
their device in a certain way and then
another component of this is that
Android is not only phones Android
involves tablets as well and the line
between tablet and phone is kind of
blurry but you know really Android you
know is really just you know well I
guess one of the ways you can describe
most Android devices right now is
touchscreens ranging from about three
inches to about 10 inches so you know
responsive design is really important
here make sure that your app can respond
to the to the size of the screen and
that you know it makes best use of white
space and best use of content in all
those different configurations and not
only that I mean Android is also it's
not only about touch you know there
there are some devices that are that are
you know d-pad focus at Google TV so
definitely think about ways in which you
can response your device in both
portrait landscape tablet phone and
different input types I think it's
pretty important the point you kind of
thought about here in this subtext it it
sounds scary as well right saying being
responsive to all these different form
factors and so forth but there really is
so much you can do very very easily
things like you know upping the font
size when you have over a certain amount
of space or you know changing the
padding and or going to like a you know
Center with margins things like that can
be like the you know an hour of work or
two hours of work and make your
application like you know vastly better
on a larger device so it really is worth
just you know trying it out on a range
of devices or emulators and seeing how
those yeah all right with that let's
jump into some quick honorable mentions
as to running super low on time first
per the guidelines for launcher I
your app icon should really be a
distinct silhouette I know there are a
couple of Google apps that don't really
you know adhere to this guideline but
that's definitely something that we're
looking into don't forget like I
mentioned don't forget the empty States
for your collections so you know if you
have nothing in a list if you have look
at let's say a to-do list right and if
you have nothing in there if you have no
to-do items all for the user some ways
to add something to do it maybe like a
plus button or introduce what is going
to happen once you add the plus button
or once you press the plus button
basically not all content in that like
it to do this might have a you know some
sample to-do items
yeah some sample to-do items like milk
cheese eggs and so on graphic assets
should be crisp I think most folks are
starting to do this correctly but
definitely make sure to provide xhdpi
and now we're liking our Samsung Galaxy
s4 HS you want xxhdpi assets those are
becoming the norm take advantage of
platform features make sure that if
you're if you're especially in fear too
in a category that is heavy on widgets
like sports or news make sure to provide
a widget and then make sure to provide
expandable notifications you know
they're it's too easy it's so so
dangerous so what I have to go get kick
okay all right sanic so you know make
sure to provide expandable notifications
they're just so easy to add
lastly notifications you should use them
correctly don't show too many
notifications show them inappropriate
fashion show them appropriate time and
then for the icons themselves a
notification that kinds of the status
bar make sure to use white icons don't
add any color because the status bar
actually automatically dims that so it's
going to look like it's gonna go from
like a blue or red to like a some sort
of maroon or some sort of dark blue is
just weird so those are the honorable
mentions very last last but not least if
you have any anti patterns that we
missed out on today and you want to you
know let us know about them and you know
share your or maybe rant about them just
kind of comment about it in either the
event or the Google+ page
and yeah we'll see what we come up with
all right so I think that was it for
that was it for today Nick just dropped
off so I guess we'll just end it here as
always I'm your host Roman Nurik see you
later guys my name's Adam cosh and over
in London we had Nick butcher
we had Nick butcher and this is that's
yeah I'm not Nick butcher that Nick book
okay all right see you guys next time